esta es radio canadá internacional
bienvenidos a que nada en las américas
que hace una emisión producida por la
sección en español del difusor público
radio canadá internacional
difundimos en directo cada viernes a las
dos y cuarto por las redes sociales en
internet y en esta emisión les
presentamos los temas destacados de la
semana y también compartimos sus
comentarios y correos electrónicos
hoy les acompañan en los micrófonos
louis
gracias a la versión radio de este
programa disponible en nuestro sitio
eres en este punto sea les presentaremos
la música de artistas que usan nombres
geográficos canadienses del grupo
llamado coco no son muchos son grupos y
personas que usan nombres de la
geografía canadiense por ejemplo está un
grupo b1 un grupo estadounidense que se
llama of montreal de montreal ellos van
a intentar un tema que se llama kato y
satán que el gato es un es un chiste y
la referencia kato en el de la pantera
rosa' del entrenador que tenía que
sorprenderle siempre a su al inspector
clouseau del saxofonista estadounidense
llamado ay quebec fallecido en 1963
escucharemos al tema
blue harlem del grupo británico arctic
monkeys los mont los monos del ártico
escucharemos adolescente fluorescente y
vamos a acabar el programa con una
canción de ti llamada iron care de sweet
micky que llegó a la presidencia de ese
país con el nombre de michel martelly y
él vivía aquí monte al bien entonces
abrimos el programa con esta ronda de
actualidad es curiosas que podemos
compartir con nuestros oyentes podemos
que curiosidades estoy pendiente de este
eclipse lunar que se va a producir en
pocas horas más en la noche de este
viernes que está anunciado como el más
largo del siglo 21 esta noche
es la famosa luna de sangre y que va a
durar cuánto tiempo 22 minutos
bueno depende de cada lugar aquí creo
que se después la si esta noche se me
equivoco algo así no sea que va a estar
lindo es son ya varios seguramente es en
otras culturas otras lecturas no hay hay
presentimientos y augurios y esas mareas
y mareos
pero más allá de todos esos presagios yo
leyendo un poco porque se da tanta
importancia a esta luna roja y es que
todos los eclipses pero este en
particular sirven además a los
astrónomos y a los científicos en
general para estudiar por ejemplo el
grado de contaminación que hay en la
atmósfera y sobre todo en nuestro caso y
quienes viven al sur más todavía poder
calcular cuál ha sido el deterioro en
los últimos en el último año del famoso
agujero de ozono ese claro gracias al
eclipse el eclipse sí porque a partir de
él el reflejo de la luz en el satélite
en la luna los científicos pueden llevar
a cabo mediciones que le permiten
establecer por ejemplo en el caso del
agujero de ozono cuánto se ha
deteriorado o reconstituidos y fue ese
es el caso así que es interesante más
allá de su color rojizo y del siempre he
hecho mira para arriba y ver una luna
enorme como la que ha ocurrido en otros
momentos y que yo siempre me he perdido
yo viví la anterior de la luna de sangre
anterior y saqué una foto tengo unas
fotos muy bonitas de salud no sé la
última creo que fue el año pasado el año
pasado no necesariamente con el que
tener más tiempo es de 102 minutos en
los eclipses por lo general duran unos
pocos instantes con correctos minutos o
pocos minutos mejor dicho este va a ser
de 102 es un poco más de una hora y
media el tiempo de mirar para arriba y
encontró la luna y yo que tengo un
telescopio mi casa ha podido intentar
manera directa además si ya tuviera
no es nada insólito sino que más bien
preocupante este lunes cuando vine a
trabajar y me desperté temprano me
encontré con la noticia de este tiroteo
en toronto de una persona un hombre
joven aparentemente dicen los dos los
servicios policiales que era una persona
con problemas psiquiátricos serios
problemas psiquiátricos que salió a las
calles a la noche y
no vale ando a gente que se encontraba
disfrutando de una noche tranquila en la
ciudad de toronto
bueno mató a dos personas una niña y una
joven de 18 años lo que estaba leyendo
ahora que están saliendo las noticias es
que hay heridos y entre esos heridos
es una historia trágica a mi juicio es
una pareja que estaba en un bar en
toronto él es un enfermero profesional
joven y su novia es una estudiante de
enfermería y cuando alguien entró a ese
lugar corriendo avisando que había una
persona tiroteo los dos salieron
auxiliar para prestar ayuda dado que
eran enfermeros y cuando salieron se
toparon con esta persona con este hombre
asesino y didí lamentablemente ella
recibió una bala y aparentemente no
podrá volver a caminar
nunca más entonces estuve leyendo eso y
me quedo pues se me queda eso en el
corazón digamos ver que la generosidad
de esta pareja pues resultó en
prácticamente
una persona que no va a poder caminar en
su vida entonces y todas las secuelas
que deja este tipo de atentados no
atentados digo tiroteos personales no es
un atentado terrorista y entonces esta
semana pues tratamos el tema de las
armas también y cómo llegan cómo es
posible no que lo que está sucediendo en
toronto se parezca a cada más cada vez
más las ciudades estadounidenses y ann
louise vos hiciste entrevista con un
experto y eso me llamó la atención si yo
a mí me llamó la atención lo que decía
varias las cosas que dijo este experto
no sé si es el mismo caso lo que
tengamos atención a la voz pero uno de
los datos que lo comentábamos ayer es
que el índice de homicidios de la ciudad
de toronto ha crecido considerablemente
en los últimos tiempos y se está
aproximando peligrosamente al de la
ciudad de nueva york que figura en el
número uno del ranking del triste
ranking de homicidios en américa y lo
que decía aparentemente esta persona
también era la razón como es posible que
tenga armas por ejemplo hablaba de una
persona en canadá que había comprado
armas como 40 y pico de armas y las y
las venden
el ingreso de armas desde estados unidos
se conoce desde hace tiempo se realiza a
través del contrabando pero en los casos
de ataques como el de este tipo muchas
veces
las armas no provienen del contrabando
desde los eeuu y las acciones que son
adquiridas a propietarios legales en un
territorio de james y uno de esos
propietarios una de esas personas
adquirió en un plazo de cinco meses más
de cuarenta y pico de armas que vendió
un buen valor a cambio por valor de 100
mil dólares la pregunta que me surge
ahora la persona se hace 100 mil dólares
con 40 armas imaginemos lo que es a
nivel de guerra la venta de armamentos
del dinero pero al madrid a mí lo que me
llama la atención es cómo una persona
puede comprar más de 40 armas en un
plazo de cinco meses ya nadie le llama
la atención y si le llama la atención
porque no han hecho algo pero aparte es
raro es muy raro porque yo por ejemplo
tengo cuando tengo actividad inusual por
ejemplo con mi tarjeta de débito voy
sacó varias veces en el día desde el
cajero me daban desde el banco me dicen
señor usted está buscando la plata de la
tarjeta porque hay una actividad inusual
me ha pasado también por ejemplo de
haber sacado dinero de un cajero que no
ya que nunca me llaman o inmediatamente
diciéndome señor usted no está en el
radio donde siempre saca dinero es usted
o sea evidentemente hay maneras de
controlar si los bancos lo hacen podría
hacerse tranquilamente con las
que hay muchas menos armas que tarjeta
de débito en el país o sea evidentemente
se podría hacer un control sano y la
laguna jurídica que existe en este caso
de la reventa de armas es justamente
cuando uno le vende su auto tiene que
informar al gobierno tiene que ir a
cambiar la carga de constancia de
constancia en el caso de la reventa de
armas hay un vacío ahí no hay un vacío
legal evidentemente esto también lo
decía el especialista cómo alguien puede
vender su arma alegremente al elemento
entre comillas digo yo no es cierto
porque se la vende el crimen organizado
en todo caso la gente que pertenece al
mundo del crimen en todo caso y no queda
registro de esa venta entonces cómo
alguien puede comprar 45 armas y
venderlas y no y no va a hacerse cargo
de esa arma si yo soy autoridad se me
ocurre a mí voy a ver a la persona que
vende las armas y señora usted tiene un
arma de tal y cual tipo donde está y la
persona te dice massa no tiene una idea
de vende y hay que dar historia cuando
yo vendo mi auto y tengo que ir con el
comprador a una oficina oficial hacer un
trámite pagar la famosa tasa de venta
y hasta que no está el trámite terminado
de dar el poder al comprador de ese
vehículo entonces con un arma cómo puedo
manejarme con tal soltura a nuestros
amigos oyentes que están viendo nuevas
por internet les preguntamos entonces
cuál es la situación en sus ciudades y
sus espacios como cómo se lleva a cabo
esto de conseguir armas si es posible o
no no sé cuál como es en los países de
américa latina si tienes puedes comprar
libremente un arma tienes que registrar
en tampoco se sería interesante existen
registros lo conozco pero cuando no la
legalmente mejor me imagino que en el
mercado negro y legalmente de haber
muchas más opciones en el caso que lo
conozco digamos una persona que le
gustaba el tiro deportivo y tenía cierta
cantidad de armas en su casa bajo
candado porque había criaturas en la
casa o sea todos bien metódica la de la
historia y bueno yo aprendí la primera y
única vez que tiré fue con esa persona
que me debo me enseñó me mostró el
respeto sobre eso pero él tenía
y cada vez que salía tenía que salir a
un papel porque uno no puede andar con
un arma por la calle si no tiene un
papel específico a eso hay que agregar
un dato pero nos tenemos que olvidar que
si bien canadá es un país que no tiene
una tradición de posesión masiva de
armas hay sí gente que las tiene por
ejemplo para destinarlas a la casa pero
la posesión de armas en todo caso se ha
facilitado ya desde hace algunos años
cuando la anterior administración del
conservador stephen harper eliminó el
registro nacional de armas el registro
federal de armas que no logró hacerlo en
quebec e intentó pero creo que no lo
logró pero es la única provincia que
mantiene el registro de armas si no me
equivoco cuaja y a partir de la
anulación de ese registro federal de
armas es que creció sustancialmente el
número de armas que circulan en países y
en américa del norte y en canadá y eeuu
sobre todo es esto del portar armas es
una vaca sagrada que solo en el oeste
rufo no sobre todo en el oeste en la
parte de alberta de la ciudad desde
calgary edmonton pero no no tanto en el
este también hay un grupo de sí pero son
muy pequeños
en comparación a lo que es alberto
exactamente porque es una zona de caos y
rural de toda la historia
pero en eeuu es muy diferente en eeuu es
un sagrado casi 6 por ley la
constitución entonces el problema es
mayor hay aquí tenemos gente que nos
saludan y el campo line seo las saludos
de munro esperando la pronta
recuperación de pablo luis balderas
muchos saludos desde santo san san
antonio chile perdón para pablo una
pronta recuperación y para los
conductores en un gran abrazo
nelson contreras rincón dice buenos días
saludos desde barranquilla de colombia
saludos también para pablo y desean de
recuperación no esta realidad tiene un
problema una mano para que la gente no
sé que escucha no no no se angustia
tiene un problema en la mano por eso
está en realidad está solo que no deja
de ser un problema importante para
alguien como el que trabaja bien no por
supuesto por supuesto pedido que no está
peligrando su vida de una forma pronta
recuperación como si hubiera menos
es un problema problema el fin que está
siendo tratado y todo así que la
recuperación también hable así
efectivamente ya que estamos justamente
hablando de nuestros amigos oyentes
vamos a la lectura algunos de los
mensajes si tienes algunos por ahí sí
señor tengo aquí algún mensaje que dice
que nos envían mejor dicho antonio
buitrago y él nos dice hola saludos de
nuevo tengo el placer y privilegio de
escucharlos desde colombia en las horas
de la tarde me dirijo a la biblioteca
municipal y desde allí los escucho por
internet y es muy grato para mí saber
que están emitiendo en español por toda
iberoamérica y en general todo el mundo
quiero decirles que escucho la onda
corta y varias emisoras mire usted ve
todavía existen onda corta casi todas me
han enviado una camiseta con el logo de
la respectiva emisora deseo entonces una
camiseta de la vuestra si lo pasa que
cuando nos cortaron la onda corta nos
cortaron la camiseta y eso venía con
claro efectivamente pues hay que decir
11 amigos oyentes que el material que
tengamos pues básicamente es todo por
internet no no hacemos ya los envíos
digamos que es otra época estamos en
internet y estamos en esta web difusión
entonces yo creo que el alguien que
inventárselo los regalos cibernéticos me
que alguna vez hicimos la
a los que uno román de algo y los
reciban y lo puedan sacar de la
computadora
así será cuando lleguen estas impresoras
tokio la maquinita para desmaterializar
acá y materializar allá ya ese tamaño no
muy trago de colombia y colombia sí
señores antonio huitrón anthony
mentalizó dice además que es un fiel un
saludo es a colombia ya nuestros amigos
allí en esa en esas regiones
tengo un correo de ramón argüello que no
sé de dónde es dice
gresham donde es gresham no sé país
gresham puso ramón argüello nos habla de
nicaragua y dice me gustaría saber por
qué en los noticieros y publicaciones de
ustedes guardan silencio sobre la
agresión de l'hort y orteguismo sobre el
sufrido pueblo de nicaragua cuando el
propio gobierno canadiense y otros
gobiernos de américa lo han condenado
siempre me ha gustado seguir las
publicaciones en las páginas de ustedes
pero me parece que deberían hacer un
enfoque noticieros
excepciones y también excepciones ramón
argüello entonces
yo creo que hay material que es
justamente hablado sobre ese tema así
que es cuestión de volver a entrar a
nuestro sitio y lo va a encontrar si
efectivamente yo hice una entrevista con
dos claro nos llevó bastante material a
la gran dante y noticias y entrevistas
final sí que está cubierto el tema bueno
es una ciudad de oregon
si yo aquí tengo un mensaje sobre la
noticia la otan elogia plan de aumentar
la talla del ejército canadiense en
respuesta a rodrigo vega gama recuerdo
dice las naciones no tienen por qué
pertenecer a una entidad militar la cual
invade países que no son afines al
gobierno mundial occidental rusia se
mantiene libre de esa alianza de
estructura de naciones y que impone la
decadente e inmoral democracia a países
que crecen por sí solos y sin la
necesidad de la
perry más democracia rusia deberá
invadir europa deberá invadir europa
para acabar con el liberalismo y
capitalismo de la otan
esto lo firma pablo en nuestro sitio de
internet aquí tengo mensaje que nos
envía en paola paola desde argentina y
dice desde de buenos aires desde
ensenada ensenada es un mes
desde allí desde ensenada buenos aires
paula nos envía mensaje y nos dice que
es una consulta y dice comentario a
quien corresponda dice para ahora me
llegó un email donde dice que dice que
gane un premio donde me adjuntan una
serie de papeles copia de cheque del
mencionado premio pero como hay tantas
estafas me pide un depósito para hacer
envío desde francia
buenos aires- esperando alguna respuesta
saludos
por favor no pongan nunca cuando piden
ellos
el número de tarjeta de crédito sigan
haciéndolo porque uno se registra
lugar hacerlo con toda la confianza del
mundo si ellos mandan un mail para
verificar si no lo hay entonces paola
allí en ensenada buenos aires pues ya
sabe de no que cada vez que alguien te
avise por correo electrónico que ganaste
algo y sobre esto será importante suma
de dinero no lo creas hay que sospechar
si a mí me mandaron que un familiar mío
en el sur de áfrica había sido raptado y
que pedían faltaban pagar dos millones
de dólares construidos es para
rescatarlo a negociar el exacto entonces
uno negocia y venía con un papel
membretado yo me metí a fijarme de dónde
venía y si una oficina de abogados de
españa que en realidad funciona yo mandé
un mail mención señor eso es una estafa
nosotros no emitimos ese tipo
efectivamente han utilizado el número y
toda la razón social de una empresa que
sí existe para poder vehiculizar esta
estafa claro que no tienen los millones
de dólares pero familiares en sudáfrica
tenés tampoco tampoco o sea que son
cepas y en el caso de que lo hubiera
tenido no sé
depende lo que están haciendo en una
investigación que hizo la emisión de la
televisión en francés aquí en radio
canadá de un grupo que realizaba este
tipo de estafas desde la india si no me
equivoco y operaban desde una desde un
local miserable con unas computadoras
que darían vergüenza hasta en el lugar
menos tecnologizado del mundo y sin
embargo parece ser que ya hay gente que
cae hay gente que paga hay gente que
cree que es verdad lo que yo vi de
canadá la las las víctimas las mayores
víctimas se encuentran las personas de
la tercera edad son las más fácil pero
por el palito yo conozco una persona que
dirección a efe o no pero que baja de
películas en una especie de pirateo
y le mandaron un mail de una conocida
empresa de teléfonos sus teléfonos apple
diciéndole que había un saldo a pagar de
400 y pico de dólares por películas
alquiladas él me dijo yo en mi vida el
que una película
imagínate la gente que si el caso sería
una compensación
bien continuamos con más cartas aquí
tengo una que nos envía ricardo que
abriera y él comenta sobre que nada y su
plan de migración 2018 ricardo cabrera
nos dice buenas noches es indudable que
leer este plan de canadá al respecto de
la inmigración es muy reconfortante los
países más poderosos son los que ven a
los inmigrantes como enemigos los
expulsan y muchos de ellos en otros los
quieren
y lo hacen o levantan muros que canadá
planifique la llegada de inmigrantes es
muy alentador el ser humano emigra y
tiene derecho a hacerlo pero eso no debe
quitar esa pose
qué es una forma de libertad de
esperanza y de intercambio cultural se
debe planificar sí pero no a impedir
gracias que nada dice ricardo cabrera
aquí tengo un pequeño comentario o
nelson contreras rincón sobre la
historia de la adquisición de las armas
dice respecto a este tema en colombia
restricciones sobre el porte y tenencia
de las mismas pero en el mercado negro
abundan muchas armas que obviamente las
autoridades no controlan o no lo pueden
hacer con las cuales se cometen muchos
delitos yo creo que diversidad debe ser
la realidad de los países en américa la
tienen a genes bueno en el mundo en
general no claro me imagino profundas ya
tengo aquí otro mensaje en este caso nos
lo envía side a núñez no sé de dónde es
ella chile gris muy bien se refiere
entonces al tema de los latinoamericanos
en quebec quienes son y se dice muy
interesante hacía falta un retrato de la
comunidad latinoamericana residente en
quebec y es verdad a veces están
bastante dispersos los datos sobre los
latinoamericanos aquí en en canadá y en
en quebec en particular donde la
comunidad a simple vista no sé si
realmente es así pero a simple vista
parece
que seguirá creciendo hace muy pocos
días donada por pleno centro de la
ciudad de montreal y creo que no hubo un
solo segundo que no dejará escuchar a él
que no dejará de escuchar a alguien
hablando en el año 8 turismo en este
momento también es cierto proveniente
sobre todo de méxico también hay muchos
venezolanos que andan por acá en fin sí
cada vez más y lo cierto es que esta es
la primera encuesta sobre la comunidad
latinoamericana en quebec y que además
los que realizaron esa encuesta van a
quieren ahora extender la a toronto
ontario y a columbia británica entonces
va a haber como otro una segunda etapa
bien más cartas sí aquí tengo un mensaje
sobre el que escribe mateo sobre se
puede curar la pedofilia tal vez si
sabemos quién es un pedófilo y también
sabemos por qué pero aún no estamos
listos para dar a conocer esa
explicación ya que hay mucho anonimato
hay mucha enfermedad en el mundo gracias
al alcohol y las drogas no es bueno
abatir nuestra responsabilidad como
humanos recurriendo a los placeres del
alcohol y las drogas porque nadie está
obligado a su consumo por cierto que
tanta publicidad nos surte sus efectos y
ese yo opino que la cura para esta
enfermedad no es una cárcel pues al
salir alguien lo mismo una y otra vez la
cura está en la propia mente del
ejecutor y están escuchando que nada de
las américas que hace el programa del
fin de semana de radio canadá
internacional en haber sido un radio de
este programa escucharemos a los
artistas of montreal
arctic monkeys hay que hay que ver y
también michel martelly su nombre
artístico sweet micky y bien pasamos
ahora a los temas que destacamos a mí me
gusta la lengua arctic monkeys me gusta
decirlo en español los monos
por eso pero imagínate un mono en el
ártico no sobreviven sobrevive bien
louis tú lo sabrás esta semana de que
vinculará la ciudad fronteriza con el
crimen y los refugiados es peligroso sí
señor desde los ataques de septiembre
del 2001 en eeuu la cuestión fronteriza
se volvió un asunto candente un tema
presente en las discusiones todo el
tiempo y con la llegada de donald trump
a la casa blanca en eeuu
y recuperó también valoro ganó aún más
espacio sobre todo a partir de los
enfrentamientos por temas fronterizos
entre eeuu y méxico pero desde hace un
tiempo a esta parte
no sé si directamente trampero parte de
su entorno se ha preocupado por la
situación en la frontera norte de eeuu
es decir esa que a nosotros nos afecta
más que es precisamente la frontera con
canadá y no son pocos quienes en eeuu
piensan que la frontera calado
estadounidense es una frontera permeable
qué quiere decir esto es una frontera
que permite sin control o sin mayor
control el paso de por un lado
contrabando ya sea de drogas o de otro
tipo de objetos y también el paso
irregular de personas esto ha llevado a
unas
parte de la clase política
estadounidense a elaborar una estrategia
para reforzar la seguridad en la
frontera y lo que dice mi entrevistado
que es david moffett un experto en
criminología y profesor de la
universidad de ottawa es que esa
estrategia presenta en eeuu no tendería
a complicar aún más la relación
fronteriza sino precisamente a asegurar
que el comercio y el turismo puede
ingresar sin mayores problemas o
traspasar las fronteras sin mayores
problemas al tiempo que se impide que
por ejemplo haya contrabando de drogas o
de armas y lo que dice él es que un
ligado a este tema y dada la reciente
creación de un ministerio tengo por aquí
el nombre del ministerio de seguridad
fronteriza y reducción del crimen
organizado unir estos dos temas la
seguridad de fronteras con el crimen
organizado y meter en la bolsa también a
los refugiados es por un lado una
torpeza política y por otro lado un
peligro porque se tiende a generalizar
un discurso
propicia e inculpar a los refugiados de
la inseguridad que sienten algunas
personas aquí en el territorio y para
terminar dice que la creación de este
este ministerio a veces solamente a una
decisión populista de parte del gobierno
federal que busca calmar las
preocupaciones del sector más
conservador del electorado con vistas a
las próximas elecciones que son el
próximo año exactamente el tule de las
aguas de una peruana canadiense que se
lanza a la política si justamente
estábamos diciendo recién sobre este
crecimiento de la comunidad
latinoamericana en canadá en montreal en
quebec y que se hace cada vez más
evidente cuando uno anda por las calles
y escuchan la lengua castellana pues
también se están destacando canadienses
de origen latinoamericano en la política
canadiense ya hablamos la semana pasada
de pablo rodríguez un ganado argentino
que hoy forma parte del gabinete
primer ministro otro hablamos también el
año pasado del nombramiento te recordará
se rufo de la una primera senadora de
origen latinoamericano rosa gálvez que
fue nombrada por trudeau también ellas
de origen peruano
y hoy estamos hablando de julia sánchez
que hay que decir julia sánchez fue la
primera persona de origen culturalmente
otro que canadiense en haber sido la
presidenta y directora general del
consejo canadiense de cooperación
internacional entonces ya es tiene una
primicia en esto y ella deja ese puesto
a partir de ayer dejó ese cargo en el
consejo canadiense para incorporarse a
la política canadiense y entonces está
dejando a ottawa y montreal y se
presenta como candidata para ser elegida
como candidata a la diputación federal
por parte del nuevo partido democrático
y lo lo interesante de esto es el
desafío que ya tiene porque se presenta
en una circunscripción que es un tramo
que se en montreal y que actualmente
todavía está en manos de quien fuera el
jefe de la oposición canadiense en el
parlamento en la época de stephen harper
que es este todo mujer que tuvo una
actuación extraordinaria hay que decirlo
en ese parlamento al nacer y al ser la
oposición oficial en aquel momento pues
entonces julia sánchez va a seguir el
camino va a intentar ser elegida como
candidata del nuevo partido democrático
para esto va a ser en el otoño para y
parece que va a ser la única que se
presenta es lo que dicen fuentes de
civis y radio canadá que es la única
candidata del nuevo partido democrático
npd que va a presentarse en esta
circunscripción entonces posiblemente va
a ser elegida y después presentarse a
las elecciones
a ser elegida como diputada entonces
conversamos con ella es una persona con
muchísima experiencia a nivel
internacional vivió en asia trabajó
muchos años en áfrica en lo que es
cooperación internacional en por
naciones unidas oxfam el csic hasta
finalmente en los últimos años ocupar el
cargo en el consejo canadiense para la
cooperación internacional entonces tiene
muchísima experiencia ella nos dijo en
la entrevista conozco muy bien cómo
funciona el sistema en el parlamento
canadiense cuáles son los canales de
influencia las alianzas que pueden
lograrse etcétera etcétera también le
preguntamos rufo cuál es el tema que
ella si es elegida diputada considera
que es prioritario y ella habló del tema
del desarrollo sostenible que es una
experta también en ese tema y que según
ella este tema abarca muchos otros
subtemas que tienen que ver con por
ejemplo la salud de la educación
entonces pues aquí está es una persona
de origen latinoamericano que puede
entonces también ocupar cargos
en canadá y se está preparando para eso
sí tuve la ocasión justamente de
entrevistarla a ella cuando estaba al
frente de esta asociación de organismos
de desarrollo internacional sí y en el
momento que el gobierno conservador
estaba estaba utilizando básicamente la
finanza el financiamiento como como
instrumento de represión política
básicamente de estos organismos
recordemos caídos porque muchísimos
cortes en ese momento claro entonces ya
se ha fogueado una de las personas que
más denunció esta política también de
stephen harper en aquel momento
efectivamente 6 bien y tú nos hablas
leonardo sobre el data transfer
proyectos del proyecto de transferencia
de datos
la historia es bastante simple aunque
para el nombre parezca complicado cuando
uno se por ejemplo se afilia a facebook
entra y pone un montón de datos y uno
decide no está más en facebook o
participar menos y esa otra red social
nueva por ejemplo y tiene que entrar
todos los datos no tiene que cargar todo
otras fotos de nuevo lo que están
haciendo las grandes de la informática
facebook google microsoft twitter por
ejemplo son estas 4 que encabeza en este
proyecto es lograr generar una
estructura para que la transferencia de
una cuenta a otra sea bajo las mismas
normas entonces uno no tenga que entrar
todos los datos de nuevo por ejemplo uno
va al médico y cambia de médico porque
cambia de provincia entonces que toda
esa información me acompañe y que sea
fácil de importar por la otra entidad o
que yo sea capaz de hacer digamos de
gerenciar eso de una manera simple sin
necesidad de tener que entrar todos los
datos
de nuevo el problema ajustable más que
uno le facilita el trabajo a los espías
exactamente el problema es que siendo de
esta manera es muchísimo fácil controlar
porque no tiene un solo elemento y que
ese elemento pues es hackeado entonces
pueden ser que quedan todas las cuentas
pero justamente están poniendo mucho
en evitar que sea claro que ese tipo de
cosas pueda suceder y para facilitar la
participación de la gente no solo en eso
por ejemplo uno hace el login para el
gimnasio y si uno cambia el gimnasio
quiere describirse en otro gimnasio toda
la información lo puede seguir a uno con
cierta facilidad por lo menos este es el
proyecto del data trans yo no les creo
esas empresas que esté reforzando la
seguridad porque hay un ejemplo muy
simple yo comprado un producto en una
empresa de china hablábamos antes de una
compra tuya en china
de un producto yo he comprado un muy
pequeño producto y muy muy económico
unos pocos dólares nada más a una
empresa que es originaria de china es la
compra le dice en forma absolutamente
legal a través de internet y el
resultado de esa compra fue que al día
siguiente comencé a recibir llamados en
mi teléfono móvil que nada tiene que ver
con esa transacción de empresas basadas
en el mismo lugar dónde está esta otra a
la que yo le compré mi producto quiere
decir qué
dice el chino xi fuego la información
por semanas fácilmente diciéndome que
debo impuestos que me van a meter a la
cárcel si estamos todos mal de impuestos
sí sí sí que además que hay una orden de
detención sí sí sí sí es terrible eso me
envió hasta que me tranquilizaron
yo dije quién se desea exámenes no no no
no no escucharon realidad siempre cuando
cuando atiendo esas risas llamadas pongo
el cronómetro de cuánto tiempo pasan en
apresarme
pero nunca mensajes en que me dicen que
fácil que es pisar el palito a la gente
en clic y suficiente en clic en sus
asientos además el dato habla de qué
cantidad de información se comparte en
esas empresas porque yo estoy haciendo
una compra por internet nunca le
comunique a esa empresa cuál es mi
teléfono ni mucho menos como hizo esa
empresa para saber cuál es mi número de
teléfono y comenzar a llamarme a mi
móvil y a mí me pasó otra cosa
simplemente búsqueda en internet ponerle
de una obra de teatro que va a pasar acá
y de repente con después cuando salgo en
búsqueda cuando empiezo después me voy
al día siguiente me voy a leer algo y me
aparece la pobreza son las famosas
cookies esas son las famosas cookies
cuando tú ingresas a un sitio en
internet existen lo que se llaman las
cookies que toman información
que visitas desde y con eso lo que hace
es orientar publicidad efecto exacto
bueno en este caso el artículo este
termina diciendo todas credenciales y
datos serán encriptados tanto
tránsito como en reposo y si utilizara
una forma de secreto perfecto donde cada
transferencia se beneficia una clave
única además de otros mecanismos e
infraestructuras de seguridad existentes
en cada una de las plataformas en
particular es decir no sólo el elemento
oeste esta manera de vehicular la
información va a estar encriptada sino
que también los lugares aún no nos lleva
la información también tienen beneficios
de ese tipo de cosas que en realidad es
que no damos cuenta que no sirven para
nada
de todos modos la información se queda
no y noruega sino en eeuu exacto
que tiene hasta ahora que facebook tiene
que recuperar la cantidad de dinero que
perdió en la bolsa pero perdió 125 mil
millones de donas y fin crédito 25 mil
millones de dólares pero recupera en 23
meses no pasando o sea el 25 por ciento
casi de su de su empresa pero sí pero es
la mayor pérdida que haya registrado una
misma empresa en una sola jornada o en
una misma jornada en la bolsa en la
historia y lo que es fascinante decir es
el grado
mismo que detrás de esta noticia porque
estamos estamos a donde cosas que no
existen que son virtuales es decir un
acuerdo en que decimos bueno vamos a dar
un valor x a esto y ahora te digo bueno
hasta pasado entonces pierde valor pero
pero en la realidad no la tiene el dueño
claro no la tienes plata virtuales no
hace lo mismo con mucha fortuna no x
persona tiene al 20 mil millones de
dólares que los tiene en su cuenta
bancaria
tienen serie en activos pasivos está
bien están escuchando radio canal
internacional programa el que da las
américas y estos temas están disponibles
en nuestro sitio en internet era de seis
mil puntos sea yo les recomiendo una
corta entrevista con un autor canadiense
y dany laferrière ha nacido en haití y
está justamente celebrando sus 30 las 30
publicaciones entonces este viernes hay
una presentación 30 libros que les
quiten todos los desde los años 80 desde
que llegó a
a montreal como refugiado político el
trabajaba como periodista en en haití y
pues asesinaron a un compañero de
trabajo suyo y le avisaron que él era el
siguiente analista así que hizo sus
maletas y fue primero a la florida y
luego a montreal cuando tuvo suerte
montreal de recibirlo a es un gran
escritor y es miembro de la academia
francesa claro ese es que es alguien muy
especial si la feria es justamente el
primer canadiense que entra a la
academia en francia lo cual allegados
suyos eres muy diplomático el muy muy
correcto pero allegados suyos no dejan
aún de sorprenderse por la reacción en
quebec
porque él y no la live porque un
inmigrante grande y ahí esa y eso se
percibe inclusive en ese a flor de piel
presta en leyendo hicieron porque él
tiene las características necesarias que
busca la academia francesa de la lengua
estamos todos de acuerdo salvo al
qué piensan son una minoría no creo que
haya un sentimiento mayoritario entre
revitalización cultural dentro del
anterior quebequense la verdad me
sorprende no entiendo porque al
contrario tendríamos tendrían que estar
muy atentos irían pero hay muchos que no
lo están y son nombres grandes dentro
del campo grande entre comillas dentro
de la de este pequeño espacio que es el
mundo de la literatura en esta provincia
francófona canadiense viene entonces
esos son los temas que os proponemos
volvemos a una segunda ronda de cartas
para tenerlos para saber que no se
escriben ustedes cómo están ustedes y yo
tengo acá uno que bien es una pregunta
que nos hace alejandro salinas sobre el
tema que era tiene en la pregunta era
del tema tienen grupos sanguíneos los
animales y alejandro salinas dice hola
mi comentario más bien es una pregunta
el rh positivo y negativo también se
encuentra en la sangre de los perros la
verdad que no tengo ideas contestó mi
perro dona sangre así que voy a
preguntar a los seres humanos
si le pagan con una bolsa enorme de
derecha área positivo y negativo voy a
plantar el perro acaba de decir que con
una bolsa de alimentos sí o sea es un
interés meramente materialista
aunque trabaje hombre no no pero es
importante eso porque tan a donar sangre
también hace cuando uno le sacan sangre
el cuerpo hace un esfuerzo para reponer
esa sangre y eso es muy bueno para el
organismo si tengo me imagino que para
los proyectos también bien sí sí sí
nadie sabe ustedes vamos a averiguar
para la próxima semana
bueno tengo un comentario sobre
solicitamos apoyo humanitario de canadá
al pueblo de jalisco méxico este mensaje
lo manda a fernando acosta riveros y
dice reciban fraternal saludo de paz y
bendiciones de jalisco donde la
situación de violencia nos tiene
aterrados e intimidados ayer se dio a
conocer que tres jóvenes estudiantes de
medios audiovisuales fueron quemados con
ácido por supuestos delincuentes ligados
al narcotráfico en jalisco se está
haciendo imposible vivir el gobierno ha
sido rebasado y además ofrece
información incompleta donde intenta
criminalizar a los jóvenes a quienes
piensan diferente y a quienes tienen una
religión diferente al catolicismo ojalá
al gobierno de canadá en muchas de sus
organizaciones humanitarias se acerquen
a jalisco sabemos que canadá a
diferencia del gobierno de eeuu es un
país amigo atentamente fernando acosta
riveros
yo tengo mensaje que envía blanca
álvarez sobre el tema neurólogo experto
en epilepsia ofrece consulta gratis en
español desde saskatchewan y ella nos
dice buenas tardes tengo a mi hijo
años y seis meses con diagnóstico de
síndrome de dravet será posible que el
doctor pueda valorar a mi niño somos de
la comunidad de querétaro aquí tengo
mensaje de éxito por miriam rodríguez
ella reacciona a un reportaje que se
hizo racismo y espectáculos críticas al
black face en la farándula
latinoamericana en canadá y medianos
dríguez dice que extremismo yo defiendo
la igualdad y el respeto a las personas
negras y no admito la discriminación
pero y ellos vargas es un personaje
hermoso muy dominicano esas son personas
que viven de esos extremismos en
organizaciones sin fines de lucro pero
reciben dinero extremistas diseña un
personaje que todos quieren mucho
no conozco llegué vargas pero creo que
la idea era que se hacía pasar por una
persona de origen africano hay todo un
debate en canadá a su apropiación
cultural entonces quizá podamos
conversar sobre ese tema la próxima
semana aquí llegamos al final de nuestro
programa estuvieron hoy con ustedes luis
laborda leonora chapman leonardo gimeno
y quien les habla ruso valencia va a un
fuerte abrazo gracias por estar con
nosotros cuídense mucho y sera
en la próxima semana adiós adiós